اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان طائره شحن
عسكريه روسيه من طراز ال 76 كانت تقل 65
اسير حرب اوكرانيا تحطمت اليوم في منطقه
متاخمه لاوكرانيا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اتهمت كيف باسقاط الطائره وقالت ان
رادارها رصد اطلاق صاروخين
اوكرانيين معنا مازن عباس الان من موسكو
مازن عباس مراسلنا في موسكو اهلا بك مازن
ام هل هل هل قدمت موسكو يعني دليلا على
تاكيدها بهذا الشكل على الاقل على لسان
وزاره الدفاع بان كيف استهدفت هذه الطائره
يعني يفترض الان انه تم تشكيل لجنه
للتحقيق في هذا الحادث وتبدا التحقيقات
ولكن بحسب تصريحات رئيس لجنه الدفاع في
البرلمان الروسي مجلس الدومه اندريه
كارتبو بان اولا شهود الاعيان افادوا
بانهم سمعوا دوي انفجارات قبل سقوط
الطائره الطائره
ورجح ان يكون اسقاط الطائره تم بصواريخ
سواء من طراز باتريوت او من طراز ار اس تي
ولكنه في النهايه ارجع الامر الى
التحقيقات التي ستبين تماما السبب المباشر
الذي ادى لاسقاط هذه الطائره ايضا تحدث
كارت بف عن ان هناك طائره اخرى ايضا من
طراز 76 كانت تقل ايضا او كان على متنها
يوجد نحو 80 اسير اوكراني وقد هبطت بسلام
في الجهه التي كانت متجهه اليها ولم تتحطم
او لم تتعرض لاي مخاطر ا كان كان هناك
صفقه تبادل جاري يا
مازن هذا ايضا ما تحدث عنه البرلمان
الروسي بان مثل هذه الحادثه يمكن ان تؤثر
على اتفاقات تبادل الاسرى باعتبار ان هذه
الاتفاقيات او المفاوضات حول ت الاسرى
يعني يتم بشكل دوري عمليا وقد تمت صفقه
منذ فتره قريبه ويعني كان هناك تخطيط
لاجراء عمليه تبادل اسرى لكن البرلماني
الروسي كتوف رجح ان يؤث ان تؤثر هذه
الحادثه وتوقف تماما عمليه تبادل الاسرب
بين روسيا واوكرانيا نعم شكرا لك مازن
عباس مراسلنا ايضا في موسكو